When I heard Michelle's story,
well I was really taken aback
and I want you to check it out.
Here's Michelle.
Hi my name is Michelle Gordon.
I am a mother of two, a single mother of two now
and I was married for 13 years.
This is now my second divorce
and I don't want to go back to the way I was feeling
the first time.
The first divorce I was devastated but I got through that
and I really you know don't wanna ever feel that way again
so I'm just trying to learn how to navigate
in this new world that we're living in
since I haven't been on a date or anything in 13 years.
I was hoping to find ways to pick myself up
and get out there again
and maybe find someone who wants to date
or companionship and someone who just wants to have fun,
not necessarily looking for a husband
because I will never get married again.
I would hopefully looking for any advice or tips
or anything that you'd be willing to share.
(crowd applauding)
So Michelle's story,
I definitely related
and I wanted to surprise her with a little talk
you know sort of like dating after divorce discussion
and I got a few of my friends together
to get her ready for the date
but the conversation is really what is the thing
that kind of surprised me the most.
Take a look.
Hi.
Oh it's so nice to meet you.
God no, I am so excited to meet you.
Are you kidding me?
We have something in common
which is I will never get married again.
Ever.
Most of the time
I think the majority of people,
although they get divorced,
they're still dealing with raising kids
and all this stuff that goes with it all the time.
So it doesn't really feel like a divorce.
It's honestly, like you're saying,
adding in all those factors and you know,
I have two children
and navigating through helping them and you know
I really want them to understand
that it has nothing to do with you, you know
and he's a great man.
He's a great person.
He's a great father.
We just are not a good couple.
Why do we focus so much on the fact that it didn't work
and the effect that that's going to have on our children
rather than the fact that we were meant to come together
to have these children?
I felt like I met Peter for a reason.
I mean we had children
and I got this out of this relationship
and I wouldn't trade that for the world
and I that's all I keep telling my children.
There's nothing I regret,
I have you.
I've never thought of it this way myself.
So I thank you for having this conversation
so maybe we could get there together.
Yeah I would love that.
How fun is it going to be to date
knowing that you will never be this entangled
with anyone again?
Ooh
I just want relief almost like, ah
cause I'm not trying to be that perfect someone,
I'm not trying to be like,
oh I hope he loves me,
I hope he falls in love with me,
I hope he's the one.
Cause I'm not looking for the one.
No.
I don't want the one.
I just want one who wants to hang out,
have fun, companionship,
but I don't want to ever be the one.
Or looking for the one.
Right.
Oh and men love that pressure too, by the way.
Yeah, exactly.
So I think you have a date coming up right?
I do.
Ronnie.
And like I'm not going to lie your pictures together.
Yeah.
When I saw them apart I was like, I don't know.
And then I saw them together and I was like, Oh
I'm excited for this date.
I'd like to introduce you to our dear friend of the show
and just a really rad woman to Mona Hoffman
who's like an expert in this field.
And I thought I would send Lee Harris your way.
He's who gets me dressed every day.
Well Michelle, I'm excited.
Yes.
(upbeat music)